hey everyone good morning it's Mike it's
uh February 3rd um 20125 and we'll get
started here on the imbalan or uh
training session and you know it's uh I
was thinking about it you know last
night with this uh sort of this trade
War I say I hate to call it a trade War
but you know the tariffs that are being
levied against uh Canada and uh Mexico
in China Mexico I think k gave in and uh
got the tariffs called off for 30 days
um but uh you know it it's adding to the
volatility of the markets you know Trump
does not disappoint the Traders when it
comes to volatility and you know that's
why it's important to uh understand
imbalances because you know when markets
are pick up in
volatility for any reason you know um
previous time Trump was President right
we ran into Co and remember those
markets uh was off the charts then and
you know vix now I think it got into got
up about 20 today
um you know I'm not saying that we we're
going to have volatility you know covid
level volatility but it's important to
understand you know the imbalances
because what often causes imbalances
is big orders by big Traders but
sometimes you know those imbalances just
uh are just the result of a big order
that's going through the market that
doesn't necessarily have
uh any long-term lasting effect on the
market and that's what the imbalancing
to do is uh filter out those imbalances
that don't have that impact on the
market so we'll get started here now so
good morning Luciano thanks for coming
out uh today I know uh you know it's
it's Monday and it's hard sometimes for
uh people to sort of get back in the
swing of things because they're busy
with work and and school but uh thanks
everyone for coming out and you know
before we begin um you know just a brief
disclaimer you know we all are adults
here Futures Trading does involve risks
the
imbalanced for trading it's not a Holy
Grail it's a tool for Traders to use um
with their trading and you know just
really briefly the imbalance there is an
orderflow based indicator for Ninja
Trader 8 that gives Traders a powerful
Edge and understanding market dynamics
specifically imbalances and and by
analyzing order flow in real time it
identifies significant imbalances
between buyers and sellers that
precede major price movements you know
there's sort of this misconception that
every
imbalance means something in the market
and I'm going to show you that not every
imbalance that takes place in the market
has meaning like I said sometimes it
could just be a big order sometimes it
could be due to lack of liquidity and
you know as a Trader you want to
differentiate between those so the
imbalanced to trade it uses Advanced
algorithm to filter out irrelevant
imbalance and focus on the imbalances
that have the potential to move the
market and this focused approach allows
you to spot institutional activity and
potential Trend reversals or or Trend
continuations um before they become
obvious to the average Trader and if
you're just looking at a simple
footprint
chart okay
the each bar you know especially this is
from this morning or sorry no um this is
from Friday rather on The e- Minis you
know you have bars that have buying
imbalances you have bars that have a lot
of selling imbalances some bars got both
buying and selling imbalances in it okay
and it's going to be hard you know if
you don't have a way to differentiate
between you know which imbalances matter
you know you're going to see sometimes
you know some bars have big um selling
imbalances in them and you think oh you
know what I got to get short here well
it's actually not those bars with the
sell balances that matter matter it's
actually the buying imbalances because
you know at the end of the day when
you're trading imbalances you don't want
to be trading in context of the market
which way the market is going so this is
that same chart now you know I sort of
LED you in because I show you sort of a
a rising market but you know anytime you
sort of come up pause you got some
selling come in here right this there's
a red bar here with five selling AB
balances you know you're thinking hey
you know what maybe the tide has turned
okay but it hasn't right you got a
couple more bars in here with you know
two Sal balances another bar up here
with three Sal balances you know one of
which is you know 500 contracts you may
be thinking that hey it's time to get
short but
actually those Sol imbalances aren't the
imbalances that matter the most it's
actually the buying and balances that
are taking place and this is the
imbalanced the default settings um you
know just highlighting the bars that
have the imbalances that matter as a
Trader right then you want to be focused
on those imbalances that matter right
and and go from there rather than just
any bar that's got imbalances you know
four five of them you might think is
strong right because that's sort of the
way we are
taught in life is the more of something
the better right but it's not really you
know the quantity rather the quality
that matters um now this is crude
oil okay you see there 's continued
pressure on this Market as it's selling
off right I mean it look like it sort of
bottomed out here around
1045 and then starts to Rally right
you're seeing a lot of buying imbalances
come in
but it's shortlived you know anytime a
little you know Market sells off bounces
up a little bit it could just be profit
taking coming in as opposed to the start
of a trend
reversal right same thing right Market
is sort of going sideways um you know
we're starting to see aggressive buying
coming in before the market sells off
right and sometimes you know Traders get
a little excited because they start
seeing a lot of imbalances coming into
the market that just don't really have
you know that that impact in the market
and this is where it's going to get
interesting right so let's just
uh talk about this right it gets
interesting because most Traders just
look at imbalances on a bar by bar basis
and completely neglect imbalances from
other time frames and you know what
we've done is we've added
multi-timeframe
analysis okay so you could actually plot
imbalances from a higher time frame or
even a shorter time frame right because
I know there's some traders that are um
you know trade a one minute chart but
they want to see signals coming in
Faster right for a 30 second chart or
even a 15-second chart or even a shorter
range based chart like a three range or
four range chart on their one minute
chart why is because they think that um
order flow and I do believe this is best
used as quickly as possible right if you
see something happen in the order flow
right and you're trading it
on um you know a different I'll say a
longer time frame
but you say you're using a one minute
chart right but if you
can and this gets into this particular
situation is is well why don't you just
use trade a 30- second chart well some
Traders don't want to look at a 30
second chart because maybe they've got
other indicators that they use on their
one minute chart but they want to take
advantage of the short-term order flow
so they'll use a 30-second um time frame
analysis on the order flow to give the
signals or you know say they're more of
a swing Trader right they or they they
believe that um you know if an imbalance
holds for say 3 minutes 5 minutes that
maybe it's going to be um you know
stronger right and you know we've done
studies that show that you know
imbalances that occur on a 3 minute time
frame are um do hold that are holding
you know tend to hold really nicely over
time but the problem is not everybody
wants to switch their chart to say a
three minute chart right or a five
minute chart so this gives you a way to
add that different time frame analysis
on your short-term chart so it's called
multi-timeframe analysis and you could
adjust it by minutes by seconds by ticks
the amount of ticks about the amount of
volume or or range um and I'll show you
guys you know on the charts today this
but I I just sort of prepared these
quick slides here for you I just want to
run through them because I knew I know
there was a question there about showing
it in real time today but I just want to
give you this quick overview before we
look at the charts so you know if you're
looking at this chart right you got a
it's got three buy uh three selling
balances okay isn't that going to be
bearish B's got three selling IM
balances
C's
got two buyer balances one cell of
balance D's got five buy balance E's got
two selling and one buying F's got one
two three buying and balances G's got
two selling and balances H has got a
buying balance followed by two selling
balance I's got three selling balance
one buying a balance j's got four
selling balance K's got four buying
balances and you know even the one after
K's got three selling balances and it's
going to be a little tricky for Traders
to try and differenti oh you know I got
to get short here no I gotta get short
up here I gotta get long here long and
then followed by a short a long short
short short short long short
well
imbalanced that guess work away from you
right and just puts it on your chart you
know with the the nice triangle to be
getting short okay there's no Longs in
there it's not telling you to get long
after this bar with three buying and
five buying and balances or three Buy bu
imbalances or two buying
imbalances okay and if you're just
looking on a simple Candlestick chart
right you can see it here short short
short um you know some
traders that use certain methods of uh
analysis they call it orderflow analysis
on a simple bar chart but they're just
looking at Price action and they'll say
well you know what there's
a a value Gap um and call it an
imbalance well yeah well not every time
there's a gap between you know the first
bar and the third bar that that
qualifies as an imbalance right um when
you're looking at the actual order flow
then you can determine then you know for
certain that there is an
imbalance okay but again by looking at a
simple bar chart you can't so what the
order flow imbalanced does is it takes
the information from the footprint
because it's reading the footprint in
the background now it is not if
footprint chart what it does is it
analyzes the information coming from the
footprint chart
to analyze it and then plot on your
existing Candlestick chart or if you
want to use a footprint chart it will
plot it on the footprint chart as well
so you're going to need to use tick
replay because um it analyzes the ticks
as they are coming through and like said
is for Ninja Trader 8 not for trading
view or any other plat form
um yeah just as a as a quick side note I
I know trading view now has a footprint
chart because I get this question a like
is you have it for trading view I I
don't the way trading view analyzes a
footprint data
is terrible in my opinion um they
aggregate prices over time the way it
trades so as opposed to actual each
trade that comes through okay and
there's a big difference right that's
why
um using the right software to analyze
order flow is very important because you
want to analyze how each trade takes
place did it actually trade um you know
on the bid or on the offer and what the
volume was that traded there okay so
multi-time frame analysis it allows you
to chart the underlying analysis to a
different time frame or chart type to
the Chart you're looking at and you know
I'm going to go I'm going to show you
some examples from this morning
um you know with multi-time frame
analysis so for example right if you
look at a one minute chart you can now
plot signals from a 10 range chart on
your one minute chart right maybe you
look
at um a f minute chart but you want to
plot signals from a one minute chart you
know there's there's a lot of ways you
can do it so you can choose tick volume
range second or minute charts to analyze
so the
default chart right there's a little
drop- down menu show you um period value
is zero so that's just the underlying
chart now the settings okay the
there's settings that you you're going
to want to adjust I'm going to go
through the different settings here okay
so minimum volume and balance again I
just want to go through these settings
because when I dive into examples from
today uh with the
chart that uh you understand what I'm
talking about so minimum volume
imbalance required default is set to
zero and for most markets you don't need
to set a
minimum if you're on extremely thin
volume markets then you might want to
consider minimum volume for the
imbalance you know five or 10 contracts
um to take to do the analysis on you so
let say you know you're in some of these
agricultural
markets and you know just it's
inherently less volume than say the e-
minis right I said e- minis currencies
crude oil Etc you don't really need to
worry about the minimum volume and
balance but if you're trading you know
say wheat um meal some of the oils you
know or bean oil yeah you might want to
adjust that okay you might want to set
it up as 10 right you might make maybe
even five right so you you do have a
minimum IM balance because you know the
last thing you want to be looking at and
and using for analysis is um you know an
imbalance of zero against four well
technically that is an imbalance right
it's it's 4 to
one you know or one against five you
know do you really want to take that as
an imbalance because just not a lot of
volume so I said in most markets you
don't need to worry about it it's when
you get into some of the thinner markets
um you may need to now we have turbo
boost and evolving bars now turbo boost
is a setting um and I'm going to show
you the difference what it looks
like that the default is disabled but
the turbo boost alerts traders to
imbalances taking place at a fair value
in a bar okay so remember imbalances can
occur anywhere in a bar they could occur
you know on the top the bottom in the
middle um you know in the point of
control but our research has shown that
when the imbalance occurs at the fair
value level in the bar it carries more
importance than other areas and when
this is enabled you will see fewer
trades fewer signals as it's going to be
more strict
on where the imbalance comes in as
opposed to sort of anywhere in the bar
okay now evolving bars if you enable
this there will be a lot more signals
appearing okay because um what evolving
bars the setting does is it analyzes
bars on how they close and how the next
Bar opens okay and if there's an extra
imbalance between them then it's going
to signal and reason being you know say
you're on a for example okay A Time
based chart I.E one minute charts the
Clos is made based on time and not price
movements so
after 60 seconds has to form a new
bar and you often have imbalances
evolving but then the bar ended so you
could have like an imbalance that's
starting to form so imagine right yeah
an imbalance is forming but you're just
running out of time
and then the bar
closes and it's like the next Bar opens
and continuing that imbalance
okay same thing with uh range based
charts right you know that as you get to
the range you hit that range boom it
starts trading then a new bar is formed
so you are going to see some more
signals coming in here because it's sort
of covering two bars in that sense but
um
you know it's just something that we've
added because we we know that that can
happen now the most important setting IM
balancer level okay default is set to
two which is the lowest you could the
lowest you can set is
one okay that's the minimum you're not
going to set it to zero I why would you
set the indicator the the strength of
the indicator to zero you just doesn't
make sense but uh the highest is six
okay so one is the minimum two is the
default it's sort of the Moder imbalance
level three is sort of the average
imbalance level get to four and five
it's slightly you know it's above
average and then stronger and then six
is the strongest okay so you can't go
over six
um you know if you're using a level six
you're going to see fewer signals
because it's looking for imbalances in
the market that are incredibly strong um
level one is the minimum level that
you're going to be looking for and
another indicator that probably going to
spend some time with I I do like to use
this because I like looking for momentum
in the market is the momentum setting
default is set to three which is sort of
the average right it's the medium
momentum
setting now to disable it you're going
to set it to zero the highest again is
six right
and one is sort of the first sign of
momentum so if you're using setting of
one right it's looking for the first
signs of momentum
some two it gets a little bit stronger
again three is the average four and five
is Just a Little Bit Stronger honestly
there's not much difference between um
four and five but when you get to six
it's strongest and again you're not
going to go above
six and lastly is the swing filter okay
now swing filter would be if you're
looking for the imbalan or signals not
imbalances themselves but actually the
imbalance signals coming in at say a
swing high or a swing low okay and
you're going to Define sort of your
swing high low or swing low period over
the swing period so to enable it you
just click on the box that says enable
swing filter and use whatever swing
period you want I default is five I I
use five as sort of my default but you
could enter you know shorter periods 1 3
or higher periods 10 15 20 I know some
guys that use go further out as a
setting of
25 okay one thing to
note if you're using the swing filter
you're going to want to disable the
momentum strength okay and vice versa if
you're using momentum strength you're
not going to want to enable the swing
filter right it goes against each other
um sometimes Traders like to come in
Click everything without understanding
what they're clicking and then they got
momentum strength ramped up and they got
swing filter ramp you know enabled and
then say there's no signals well it's
because you're you're looking for a
swing to occur in the middle of momentum
it's just not going to happen Okay so
that's just something to keep in mind um
if you're using it okay
so what I'm going to do here I'm going
to talk about a couple of the settings
but I'll just make it Easy by showing
you guys um charts and I I'll just use
Simple
uh bar charts okay as opposed to
um a footprint chart for this
presentation cuz you know I I know not
everybody uses a footprint chart and
pretty much everyone is familiar with a
simple bar
chart hang on let me drink something
here I'm about to cough so okay so let's
just
uh disable this I I'll take it off here
and you know what for now I'll talk
about bonds later but um I'll talk about
Euro currency first
okay so to add the
indicator it's really simple you just go
find it in here in balancer you know
obviously you're going to need to use
your license token for this uh when you
get it you'll be sent the license token
and these are the default settings so
you don't need to worry about a
template okay because the default
settings is sort of going to be your
your jumping off point for pretty much
every Market okay so just you know you
load it up enter your license token
click
apply and you can see here minimum
imbalance volume is off turbo boost is
off evolving bars is off this imbalan or
level is set to two momentum strength is
set to three these are the defaults
swing filter is off there's also a sound
alert
um that you could enable Okay now we do
I do like to draw out these zones until
tested that's why you see red zones
right let me get the crosshairs up
here right blue zones for bullish red
for bearish I'm a visual person you know
I like to
use levels um when I see a level form
right a bullish one or a bearish
one and I see the market not coming back
to it like within the next bar right
then I know that hey you know what
potentially we we could be you know
running all right in a direction as you
can see here right this was a small
little Runner down here but then here
you had a nice big runner from you know
the uh 66 area all the way up till you
get your bearish signal at at 92 and
back down um another one down here
obviously that big jump up um couple
hours ago and now we're sort of working
our way back down we working our way
back up and this is just the default
settings okay
so turbo boost just really
quick cup High okay so what it's going
to do is it's going to look for those
imbalances that come in
at you know what we determine as fair
value so you can see it's cleaned up the
chart a bit okay right you're seeing not
as many signals um you know there was a
bunch showing down here I think there
was a cell down here cleans it up a
little bit because now it's getting a
little bit stricter on where the
imbalances occur right if I disable
it right if you remember what it looked
like um right you're seeing you know
signal here three buy signals
here one two 3 four sell Buy sell buy
buy
buy whereas with it on there
is less all right even up in the near
that high that we just made there was
some signals in here so it cleans it up
a little bit um you know whether you
want to use it on your Market is
something you can test or not now
evolving right like I said is going to
have more signals so disabled turbo
boost I'll turn on evolving
so well let's just go back to this is
the chart without evolving okay take a
look at that right and you can see
you know there's 1 2 3 four okay so you
have a buy a sell and four buys down
here um You probably see a lot more
coming
in I'm just using that as my
reference all right so one two three
four five uh is that six here so you're
seeing a lot more buys and sells signals
coming in okay just you know here 1 2 3
4 cuz it's taking inal es that are
occurring over two bars you know where
one bar ends and the next bar
forms and again you
know if you're using evolving bars um
you you might want to two two one of two
things one strengthen the momentum
strength to a higher level um highest
you go is six okay which again cleans it
up a bit more so you're not seeing as
many um you know bad buys or bads cells
I mean you still get some after the end
of the move um you could also you know
start using a higher imbalan level go
from two to four you know or even two to
three
um right and again it's it's starting to
clean it up a little bit more uh six
again you if you're using six as your
imbalan or level with six as
a momentum strength level um you know
that's as high as you could go on both
of them so this is with the evolving
bars IM balancer level set to six
momentum strength set to six so
obviously you're catching this nice move
down right now that's taking place here
you caught this move up you know earlier
this morning you know up down back
up then this one would have liked to
perform better this one just went
sideways before it went back
down that is and you could also you know
just go back to sort of the default
setting two and
three okay if you
remember right there's a lot of signals
with the default setting with evolving
bars can actually use both turbo boost
and evolving bars right because you know
in a bar fair value doesn't necessarily
mean right in the middle of the bar
right it could be at different locations
in a bar and this is when it's occurring
you know over two bars
in their fail value so you know
something you can uh get used to but
again you know one of the settings that
I like to use besides the default is I
like to use two and
six usually what I'll do when I go to a
new market is I'll use two and
six or I'll use the default but then
I'll adjust it to 2 and six and see how
it looks
um you know if you went down to zero if
you turned off
momentum okay and you're using the
default level of
two um obviously you're going to see a
lot of signals okay
now even if you went to one which is the
lowest IM balancer level you should see
that's probably going to give you the
most
signals what you're going to do is if
you're using one with no momentum
strength might be turn on the swing
filter okay
for finding
potential turning points right and
that's with this filter
set at five you know I mean if you
wanted to you you could
adjust higher levels you know the more
higher the level the swing filter the
less signals you're going to see just
keep that in
mind um okay so let's just go back here
go back to the default two and three now
I had mentioned right you could adjust
your different time frames so keep it on
the default of two and three just to
show you um say you want to use a higher
time frame 3
minutes all right again this is with the
default setting of two and
three okay there you see how it looks
with the higher time frame I mean you
could even if you wanted to I I don't
think it's really necessary to go out to
minutes but I don't even know what it's
going to look
like you know here on on volatile
markets
um sort of the the The Logical thinking
is well if I have an imbalance that's
holding over 15 minutes it's got to be
strong well
not necessarily and and the point that I
want to make is if you're going out 15
minutes or if you're trading on a one
minute chart and you're trying to look
for a level on a 15-minute chart what I
would use it for not as a buy or sell
signal but as a potential stopping point
in the market will it be right sometimes
right but not always because if it's a
volatile Market it can blow through
levels but you can see areas you know
roughly this is 15 minutes you know here
it came right to that level here sort of
traded a little bit through it here we
got a level forming obviously here we
blew through it um you here it sort of
stopped you're just sort of going
back you know it's up to you I I I don't
necessarily recommend going out 15
minutes in uh in order flow or you can
even go down to
seconds right I mean 15 seconds I'll
just keep the 15
there you say you're scalper or
something um you know you're going to
get a lot of signals on a
15sec time frame I think that's too
short you know me I like have a little
uh calm in my trading keep it around 30
which I think is just fast enough for
most markets you because it's going to
give you enough information because
again you know remember at the end of
the day you don't want to just trade an
imbalance because it's a big order going
through okay so if it's 30 seconds if
it's going to hold over 30 seconds I I
think that it's pretty legitimate you
can go by even you know ticks you know
say you want to use a 100 tick
chart again these are just the defaults
you can adjust that or I we'll show you
some other markets with sort of
different
defaults um this based on 100 tick chart
again you know today Market's a bit more
volatile 233 you know people like to use
fibs
233 tick chart um same thing with volume
you know you could
use um you know again you know 233
volume is kind of light right now but uh
say you wanted to use I don't know
987 and
again volume at 987 versus 1,000 there's
not much difference searching contracts
but um I do know some people Traders
like to use fibs
this is uh 1, or 987 volume okay again
you know not bad you could also use uh
you know range based charts if you want
an eight range or say a 10 range you
know signals based off a of a range
based chart you can do that as
well
okay so there a lot you know even you
can even go you know shorter you know
four obviously smaller the range faster
the chart the more signals you're going
to
see okay you could just
see very fast coming in there
um I want spend a little bit of time
talking about interest rates bonds
because you know interest rates
is
they we are in a very interest rate
sensitive Market okay and
the reason I want to spend some time
talking about interest rates because you
know I know a lot of Traders you know
get involved in the markets because of
trading NASDAQ right and trading snps
you know NASDAQ is very seductive Market
because it's got very big moves
and the guys that I know that have been
trading the
longest tend to stick to markets that
move the slowest and the reason being is
you know uh say Capital preservation CU
you can be wrong in the bonds but it's
something you know these markets that
trade solid volume you know 10 years
especially um there's ample liquidity
right you don't run into these voids
of excess you know of lack of liquidity
where the Market's going to shoot 30 40
handles on you in in 15 seconds right I
mean the market the order book in market
like Bond or 10 years is very
solid and it's driven really by
institutional Traders okay I mean there
are a lot of retail traders in there but
compared to the size that the
institutional Traders trade in a market
in the interest
rates they the the retail Traders are
just like little bugs on the windshield
so to speak
um but you know I like to look if I was
looking at a this is a Time based chart
right this is a one minute chart and
just uh see if I got a footprint here
this my footprint I'll just get a a
quick footprint here
of bonds
okay so
Bonds on a one minute
chart okay so here you got the IM
balancer we got the trader
right I mean you know granted today you
know 's a lot of noise in the market a
lot of information coming out you
normally if you're trading a bonds or
even tens you on a one minute chart
right I I I've always advocated for
trading interest rates more of on a
range based chart than a Time based
chart because if you're on a Time based
chart it could just trade the bid in the
offer for several minutes you know at a
at a time at least like I said today we
got a bit more volatility in the market
but this is just get the crosshairs here
right where here at least you're trading
bid and offer one tick above one tick
below but there's a lot of times where
you know market like the 10 is just
going sideways like sort of a bit like
uh you know like this how it was trading
overnight you get you can get that a lot
in these big markets that trade a lot of
volume just because the book is so thick
so this is not it here this one what I
want so go back to the bonds okay what
you can do so this is a one minute
chart is you could set it to a for range
chart the problem
is you're using a one minute chart
Market moves slow so maybe you want to
trade signals based off of a four range
chart and just manage it on a one minute
chart okay now this is four range okay
which is you know there's some decent
signals cuz again you know like I was
talking about the traders that I know
that trade interest rates the nice thing
is you know they generally are able to
move size because there is that
liquidity and it's the Market's not
going to move much right they're just
looking to get a few ticks for decent
size you know by decent size I'm talking
about 2550 contracts
um three range which is about as short
as you can go I didn't say there's a
minimum range but
I'll just show you if you go down to two
I don't think you'll see any
signals shouldn't if it's I mean you're
well there are signals on the two range
chart but because it does cover three
price ranges what you want to be able to
do right is you want to sort of trade
enough price
movement within a certain time period
right so you can go down two but again I
think two is a bit small I like three
three
range I think this gives you enough uh
volume and price movement so this is
what it looks like on you know on a one
minute
chart right because if I was just
looking at
signals based off of a one minute chart
in
bonds okay you know granted you know
today you do have a lot of
movement you know I do run into you a
bad trade here a nice little trade here
this one's coming in a bit late you
don't really get that kickoff here
before that move
up simply because the market is just s
going sideways over this time period
right really you know how bonds can move
is normally how it looked like last
night here is how it looks like normally
during the US day session again you know
we're in the middle of
uh we're not in the middle but we just
started a trump presidency so I do
expect volatility to start to pick
up but not every day is going to be as
as big a movement whereas if you're
using a four range you know if you're
trading here let's go change this to a
four
range
chart okay so you can see where the
signals are are sort of coming in
there okay
but imagine if you can just
trade a better time frame right so you
could find the time frame that is going
to you know perform I say perform better
but you know a time frame for your your
trading that you get decent signals get
decent
movements right because if I
were say let's take a look at tens
okay you know 10 is a very liquid market
right you see short short short some
long some shorts um this is with the 4
range setting oh sorry that's just with
the one minute but if I go down to the
range right three I should capture
more of the excuse me more of the up and
down fluctuations that's taking
place in the market oh surprisingly not
so much you got sell here buy that's
just going sideways
there right see nice buy
there and again you could adjust it the
imbalan or level the imbalancing that's
with the default you know
one and three I sorry two and three if
you go to a shorter
um technically you should see a little
bit more and even if you go
to the next setting you know the
evolving bars um you're probably going
to see even
more open up this chart here
calculating
there right so the evolving bars just
really catching the move up the move
down the move back up a little drop here
move up move down move up move down
um you go back to Euro currency
okay so you see a lot there so you're
going to want
to you know with different markets
right especially you know like a euro
currency right you're not going to use a
three- range chart right you're fine
with a minute base chart or you know 10
range
chart but again you know the the default
settings of two and three I think are a
great starting point for all all
markets you know if you're using
evolving bars you're going to get more
signals and so it's going to be Market
dependent on on what you're using it
with but anyway I'm going to take a look
at uh some questions here
um run asks about uh yeah the
uh yeah R these are entries these are
not exits
because you're asking about the exits
well obviously you can trade it till you
get the reversal signal coming in um or
you can trade it as you know with with
targets okay based off of
normal Market rotations
okay because again you know everybody
trades differently like for me I have
certain movements price movements that
I'm looking for in the markets that I
look at
um unfortunately it does you know the
way I trade does keep me out of you know
these big bars like this where just
jumps up from you know say 78 all the
way up to you know basically um 90 98
because I got to take profit in
there right whereas I know other Traders
will sit there and they'll watch the
actual order flow you know we're in
these markets now where volatility is
picking up you're going to get big
movements like that
okay um but it is not going to be in the
toolbox or or flows Trader the footprint
chart
um this is a standalone indicator
because it's got other things that go
into with and so to put it actually in
the or full trator or or toolbox um this
just not going to be in
there um Chris says oh your computer
crashed so let me just uh copy your
question here um Chris and take care of
that run yeah you should be able to uh
use it with markers as well as um Blood
Hound um yeah you can use uh toolbox
with blood hound
so my uh
programmer has confirmed that
let me I'm just copying this question
here just bear with me here you hear a
lot of clicking that's me trying to copy
paste Chris's thing
um go back to some of the other
questions
here well okay Tim asked about e- minis
this
morning oh back above 6
,000 big jump
there let me drink something while I'm
waiting for this chart to load this
gives you an idea of how volatile these
markets are I mean look at this we've
jumped almost not 100 S&P points but you
know from about
50 all the way up to 35 and we did most
of that move very quickly
um John asked about uh to no it's not
going to be on on you know the problem
is with these all these different
software trading platforms is they all
got different languages for the most
part
um
and not only that but they also some of
them
handled data differently right like I
explained about uh
trading view right the way it handles
data is it's almost in my opinion it's
negligent criminal negligence as far as
um handling the
data now okay so I got this set as 10
range chart which I don't want to use
here in snps I'll just use the simple
underlying chart of that and I I'll use
you know I'll make it a little bit
stronger I'll use four as the imbalan or
level because again it's it's a little
bit volatile right now I'll try and
balance strength at
10 um but no it's it's prob of the
problem is you know on different
platforms since it's different languages
I need different programmers and problem
is what I've found over the
years it's like the guy that programmed
this is guy that program majority of all
my other indicators as well as my
footprint chart he understands order
flow and sometimes you know I
start going to other
programmers they don't understand the
order flow how how to use order flow
okay so it does uh does create some
problems
so you know this is how it looks again
just I ramped up some of the settings
right IM balancer level to four might be
a little bit too strong momentum
strength is six this is the underlying
chart if I kept it at two and
three you know us sometimes you know if
if I feel a market is volatile I'll use
a I say longer term chart like a 3
minute chart analysis on
there I said right now during Us hours
in the
snps you're going to see you're going to
see crazy movements
um where it just turns on a dime like
you saw right here it just literally
turned on this dime and then just
immediately shot up and it is shot up
from what is that uh 5050 50 and a half
straight up
to 6,000 right 50 point move in one in
five minutes basically which is insane
right that's the markets that you're
dealing with um overnight you know
things were a little bit calmer right
and you're seeing some in my opinion
some nice smoother moves if you were
to go here you know like I said if you
adjust it out a little bit you know you
can even do you know I don't know what
it's going to look at
but you know we get caught up in time
frames of 1 minute 2 minute three minute
you do like minute and a half would be
um you know something like 90
seconds
um Jacob
asks well Eric asks what's the best time
frame for orderflow there is no one best
time frame
because it comes down to what's best for
you and your your sort of your your own
trading profile right your avatar so to
speak how much risk are you willing to
take you know because again not
everyone's going to trade the same
market so saying what's the best time
frame well there was the best time frame
for me in E minis so this is like a 90c
chart
in in minis or not 90 second chart but
90 second time frame
analysis um you know from last night to
this morning so it's catching a little
bit more of that move just cuz you know
Market's a little bit more volatile than
others again for
Nasdaq because that's the next question
so to answer Eric's question what's the
best time for you it depends on what
you're trading and
um your own trading profile okay I can't
answer that that's a question that an
individual Trader has to answer you know
if it was up to me I tell people you
know there's certain markets I think you
know a lot of Traders can stick to I
think Ultra bonds is is a good market
right I think bonds
fives good markets to trade um you know
I even
think some of the the
grains are good markets right whether
you're trading it on you know a one
minute chart like this is soy meal I I
find this a lot easier to trade than
trying to trade say um m Q right I
mean why put myself because everyone's
posting charts on Facebook and and
Twitter of mq I saw some guy oh trading
NQ is so easy get 25 points out you know
the daily range is 60 points I'm able to
pull 25 points
out daily like that like three times a
day and you know everyone's oh you know
patting him on the back well I know that
guy's not going to
last right CU you know remember during
during Co
all right when you're getting these
insane daily price
ranges um everyone was the greatest
Trader
ever right I remember reading some
article about some some woman who's
12-year old son was made 30% in 90 days
well you could have bought anything
right and it and it went up if you
bought it at the right time and it's got
nothing to do with trading it was just
more to do with luck
where is that guy right I mean you could
go back on Tik Tok and watch the videos
from four years ago five years ago and
everyone talking about how easy it was
to trade where are they now right
they're not there they're not trading
anymore um that's why I think that
choosing the right Market is important
so this is NQ today and this is just
again with that chart that I had up
earlier for NQ it's the 902 chart with a
default of two and three how's it look I
mean
okay I mean you got this your face
ripped off on this move if you don't
have a stop in
there but you know that's what you're
deal with when you deal with highly
volatile markets um in the overnight
session again you
know doesn't look like you know doesn't
look like move much here right when you
look at these moves you dissect it but
this is a move from say 40 all the way
up to 80 right these These are big moves
taking place overnight but they dwarf
the move that we just saw from you know
what is that like
120 here not even
117 all the way up to 97 this is God
this insane it's a 70 point move I just
think you know that's just me but I know
there's other markets out there that
with the exact same settings you get
some nice movements you can trade right
and you're not sitting there you know
here's your face Ripper but you know
it's not it's not
uh it's not abusing you so there there's
other markets out there again you
know this is the drawback of getting
involved on social media everyone is
posting and Q again you know if you're
trading NQ or minis whatever you're
successful with it great but if you find
yourself struggling with it right
getting stopped out Etc look at other
markets there's a lot of other markets
out there to trade
um Judith asks yourl pulse includes
information on imbalances does this
product add more information or provide
same
inval balance information as or no it
looks at something completely different
um than the
pulse
it's what
the pulse looks at just really briefly
is it's watching how
the transactions taken on the bid in the
offer really looking for some first
signs of
momentum um taking place there whereas
the
imbalanced and sort of differentiating
because you know every bar right is
going to
have imbalances by or sells okay and
what differentiates a buy and sell in
balance from any other one like here
right mean you're looking at this here
in the
bonds or tens this is 10 years every
Bar's got a buying and selling or a
selling in Balance some bars got both
buying and selling IM balance well which
ones matter which ones
don't okay so like pulse would not show
anything here at all
okay would not show any buys or sells
pulse you need a bit of one you're going
to need a bit of price
movement and you're not getting it like
you know if you got no price movement
you're not going to get any
signals especially if a Market's going
sideways whereas IM balancer for
Market's going sideways it can detect
what's happening on
the
um on the imbalances taking place there
okay uh Jacob says can you show y min's
on an eight range chart okay
anyway let wait for this chart to come
up
here this is 10 years on an eight range
actually not bad on
the it give you a nice signal there I
don't NE honestly I've never really
looked at a tenure on an8 Range but
um in case you're wondering what it
looked like so let's just go back to the
minis
here8
range you know when you flip the charts
you know especially you know on some
markets that do trade a lot of volume
okay well this is the footprint that's
why it's taking
longer it does can take some
time again what is this what I got it
set at so chart zero momentum strength
two sorry bouncer level two and six but
again see you can see in here right it's
it's just giving you some sell signals
down in there some buys coming in
here buy some sells there this is an
eight
range obviously the other thing you can
do again if that that's if you trade an
eight range if you
use a minute base
chart can even set it to um eight range
just give it a
second this is the footprint if I was
showing you on this other one but
uh I could change this to range right so
this is a one minute chart
okay again you
know depending on the market you are
going to want to adjust the imbalance or
level default two momentum strength
three is your starting point now one
thing to bear in mind right the way the
S&P are trading right
now an eight range chart most
bars just off doing it visually looking
at it is about 16 ranges it's about 16
range bar so you're using an a you're
doing analysis on an eight
range you know on a on a time frame or a
chart type that's coming in a little bit
more so I can see it says calculating up
here but we'll see how it looks I'm
curious also
Jacob says
um
okay if I understand from what I see the
imbalan or band start at the close of
the bar where the imbalance occurs yes
but the signal is showing at the
following bar is that correct well
that's using the trade entry signal okay
so here you're seeing signals this is
based off of
the eight range on
the so like here it's forming
here on the um one minute chart so
getting back to Jacob's question where
is it here a swing meal just really
quick he was asking about this I didn't
cover this but this is the trade entry
signal because he's saying if he
understands it
correctly what he sees is the
signal the up or down triangle coming in
after where this zone is being drawn out
that's cuz I that's the trade entry
signal if I disable that okay what
you're going to see is like up here it
the triangle was coming in here now it's
coming in on the actual bar itself okay
it's coming in here here here here here
here there
um I like to use what the trade entry
signal does is it's looking at
okay so what just really quick what it
does here so just make this chart bigger
it's easier to
see you see this bar right here this big
green bar right you got the The Zone
being drawn out it's coming in at the
bottom of the bar that's where your stop
would be then the actual Buy Signal is
coming in here this blue up
triangle so this one yeah it does work
out but what the trade entry signal
does is it shifts over the signal so
remember you were seeing a sell signal
come in here now here's your Buy Signal
because the market has to move at least
two ticks over two bars for the signal
to come in right that's why you're not
seeing a sell signal
here okay so it's keeping me out of this
bad
trade and it's confirming this long
trade coming in here based off of the
order flow okay so you're seeing
obviously you know less signals coming
in up
here without
the sorry with the trade entry signal if
I have the dis trade entry signal
disabled right so now you're
seeing here right you're seeing that
short coming in here right which is not
really one you want to be taking um yeah
you got that long where it just sort of
went sideways dipped down below probably
would have stopped you out so the trade
entry signal is one where it just sort
of shifts it over uh for
you
um Roger you also got a new computer
everyone's getting new computers except
me I got it called whoops I got to call
Dell one of my computers crashed
recently
um anyway I'm just going to take a look
at some of these questions
um Nelson ask sorry can you please show
this on an NQ chart with two-minute time
frame and there's a signal print when
the bar is fully closed well yeah
getting to the printing
part as the bar is forming it will
either print or not print but once the
bar is closed because you know when a
bar is forming because he's asking about
NQ but let me get
to let's put up inq on here
and this question is you as the bar is
forming will it show will it not show as
the imbalances once the imbalance
conditions are met it will show
however once
the but it can change you know because
the imbalances could be there they could
disappear as more um trading takes place
okay but once the bar closes if it's
there it will remain there if it's not
there it will not show up there so so
once that bar
closes that's it okay but as the bar is
forming the signal could be there it
could not be there um it could go back
and forth so this is NQ this is a one
minute chart you ask for a two-minute
chart let just pull that up
um Antonis ask what's sort of the why I
use this instead of the show hand
indicator what's the cons and the
advantages pros and cons well showan
deals with uh liquidity volume this
deals with imbalance they deal with
completely different things in the order
flow this is a two-minute chart but uh I
think I have that I'll just go back to
the chart type zero
and this is just with the imbalan or
level
of two the moner strength of three the
defaults um it just it just reads
different parts of order flow um IM
balancer deals with certain things in
the order flow showan deals with
completely different things in the
orderflow so this is the two-minute
chart with the default
settings and Q here it was a buy there
sell Buy sell um
you
know how it look overnight again you
know today is kind of a funky day
because we did have that big gap down on
when we reopened overnight seems a bit
tame you know some decent Buys in here
again doesn't look like much of a move
but you're talking a move from 130 all
the way up to 230 it's a 100 Point move
here which is nothing compared to what
you're looking at right now um Friday
this is the 2-minute
chart and did capture a lot of that late
move down most of the move up on
Friday last
Thursday what do we have here you know
let's move up you know again I don't
know how you guys do it I I just prefer
markets that aren't as uh insanely
volatile as uh inq so my hats off to you
guys but
uh yeah um this is how NQ
looks Frank asks
uh can you explain this indicator with
your other indicators like Delta scalper
turns and pulse well yeah I mean they
different parts of order flow that
they're analyzing and you know if you're
analyzing the order flow right I mean
there's so many order flow
is amazing information you're getting
from the order flow okay you know you
have Delta where what Delta scalper
focuses on pulse which is reading the
actual what's taking place inside the
bar right how the volume is
transacting and not just how it's
transacting where it's transacting um
imbalan obviously deals with imbalances
primarily um there's other things that
go into it turns also deals with volume
where it's coming in in the bar
um then you because your next part of
your question is you know can you use
them together
well it depends right because something
like the turns ideally is meant for
reversals right that's why it's called
turns it's looking for Market
turns there and you know sometimes when
you
get the information for a turn right
it's just different information than
you're going to see with say the
imbalancing to stack each indicator on
top of them and say oh I got a signal
for Delta scalper pulse turn show hands
and IM
balancer that's the trade to take well
to get all five of them showing up at
once or say four out of five is not
going to be that common okay and so what
you're going to do you're going to end
up getting yourself out of a lot of
Trades that you probably don't want you
know you're going to miss things
but that's how it is right
um you know I think that a lot of
Traders sort of sort of Fallen I mean
not not you I'm not picking on you or
something but um I do know that I watch
a lot of videos um you know I spend God
knows how many hours in the car driving
my kids to their activities so I I watch
lot of YouTube and listen to a lot of
videos and stuff and I see people
talking about oh this is how you do it
right you stack Mac D on top of adx on
top of um RSI on top of this and when
you get these 10 signals in a row you
know that that's the trade you take but
it's all looking at the exact same piece
of information right it's just looking
at price over sort of a different time
frames you know because they're they're
bastardized sort of moving averages in
that sense um whereas information you
gather from the bars Delta itself has a
different meaning than say the volume
transacting or where you know how the
point of control is transacting in a
bar okay because they're completely
different pieces of information right
because like here right you see this red
candle it's got positive
Delta okay normally you're going to see
a red candle it's going to have negative
Delta okay what what's taking place is
right this Market is sort of coming down
finding liquidity there's some little
sign of absorption taking place here
right you can see the heavier volume 202
151 here coming in towards the bottom of
the
bar this is a weak sign of absorption
but that is a sign of
absorption okay so again you know
sometimes stacking different parts I
mean you can stack parts of orderflow
that are conducive to each
other um you know
like momentum things right thin prints
um zero prints
uh you know together with you know maybe
some sort of imbalance reversal or
something and you could build off of
that that's what we have the toolbox for
um so you know that's not say you can't
do it but with these Standalone
indicators like Delta scalper pulse
turns IM balancer
Etc they're a little bit more advanced
than just the the bit and piece of the
order flow in itself
um well the the
arrows will plot as the bar is forming
because again you know as the bar is
forming it could be
something in the orderflow happening
right now
but if the bar closes and it's there it
will remain there so it's not going to
like repaint or anything like that okay
so you saw one here there
was well it wasn't forming yet but it
was just sort of showing some flashes
taking place
there yeah Jacob uh you're asking about
The Blood Hound
yeah Peter's been working with the guys
that blood hound over it
um anyway guys
uh one other question here can I use a s
two questions
from three questions John ask about
where do you get your data from
um
ninja Trader brokerage um cqg Continuum
but you can use it with uh kinetic data
IQ feed Etc if you know you want
obviously you need real-time data um for
it like on the thing that killed me on
trading view people say make a video on
trading view make a tra video on trading
View's footprint which I'm been working
on realtime data there trading view I
don't know if people that use trading I
don't use trading view but I I signed up
for it just to look at their
footprint it's like $60 a month and it's
like delayed data on the footprint um if
you want real time data on the footprint
it's like $200 or something if you buy
pay for 12 years in advance or 12 months
in advance whereas a ninja Trader you
just open an account with
them and you can subscribe to the data
feed uh I get you only need level one
one data you don't need level two but I
subscribe to level two anyway cuz I like
to look at the the depth of Market every
once in a while um CME bundle so CME CB
NX comx as well as urex well just the
CME products CME Group stuff which
includes cblt NX it's like $40 a month
um I add in the urex stuff that just
makes it an extra 20 bucks so it's like
$64 I pay per month for the data um
Alon can you use it on atas no um for
Ninja Trader um would this work well on
reversal charts well the chart has to
be one that you could use with tick
replay okay so like on and there are
some reversal charts out there from
third parties that do have that like for
example here on ninja Trader the in the
native one the native Rinko you can't
use it on because you don't have tick
replay but you know something like
kinashi where you get enable tick replay
yeah you
can um well it doesn't read Frank it
doesn't read level two
data so you don't need it but again you
know level two is if you're just looking
at the the depth of Market I like to
look at the depth of Market every once
in a while if I'm trading you know some
of these currencies just out of
curiosity more than anything else when I
get
bored but uh yeah um anyway don't worry
aim I'm going to send out the replay uh
later or post it up on
YouTube okay all right everyone so I'll
end it there I don't want to keep you
guys on all all day long but um again
you know thanks for taking the time out
to uh you know share it with me so again
you know right now we got to do have a
special offer it's $2.99 for the
lifetime license it's per computer
because it's linked to the ninja Trader
machine
ID so if you're going to put it on two
different computers you do need uh two
different licenses but if you do need
two different licenses just message me
and I'll I'll give you a discount on the
second one um usually you know what you
know we're living in this age of VP vpns
you know a lot of people use those so
they could access it from anywhere
um that way you don't need additional
licenses but um yeah just go to
orderflows oncom
imbalan um to take advantage of this
deal and again you know price will go up
to
$499 by later this week um not sure what
day but um towards the end of the week
so just click on that link to get
started and I'll see you guys on the
inside so take care everyone I'll catch
you
later
e
e e